[Musique]
ta taille
à pattaya
[Musique]
ouah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tiens je fais un bon jour pour cette
deuxième émission de campagne ce que
vous lisez la presse quand vous faites
campagne et rapidement ce que vous avez
vu ce que vous avez lu celle clip qui
parlait des prestations de tous les
candidats et guéré qui d'ailleurs s'est
pas braillard lewy en mal c'est pas
brillant c'est pas brillant je crois que
tous les hommes politiques ont de grands
progrès à faire en matière de
communication d'ailleurs moi je ne peux
plus supporter la langue de bois mais je
conçois bien que j'ai aussi moi même de
grands progrès à faire
cela dit a tout de même un problème
c'est qu'on joue une campagne électorale
de cette importance sur l'image sur la
télévision et que ça devrait être
beaucoup plus les solutions et décider
de fonds je voudrais quand même vous
lire un petit passage que j'ai relevé
dans un journal qui vous concerne près
particulièrement qui est intéressant
voilà ce que ça dit hier pierre juquin
était comme le nouveau prof de gym qui
pour sa première leçon s'emballe en
expliquant à ses élèves étonné qu'à la
fin du semestre
ils grimperont en 8e division étonné
étonné il y aura des surprises
mon score sera peut-être déjà une
surprise et puis nous irons loin
vous avez vu l'équipe de créteil en foot
je suis david contre goliath
c'est david qui gagne alors vous vous
dites ça sans doute pour me permet de
présenter david assouline et vient jouer
qui vous accompagnent aujourd'hui vous
avez voulu qu'il soit là pourquoi
qu'elles s'étaient tous la directrice de
ma campagne est une militante anti
racistes depuis très longtemps
david assouline est bien connue de tous
les téléspectateurs puisqu'il a été l'un
des représentants du mouvement étudiant
de l'hiver précédent que je comprends
bien mais pourquoi sont-ils veut
pourquoi très simple vous savez les
français ne sont pas et les immigrés qui
vivent en france ne sont pas des veaux
il se passe beaucoup de choses
contrairement à ce que dit la classe
politique
moi j'ai choisi qu'elles s'étaient tous
david assouline et beaucoup d'autres
gens qui m'entourent parce que je suis
le candidat de tous ceux et toutes
celles qui n'arrivent pas à s'exprimer à
travers la vie politique telle qu'elle
fonctionne aujourd'hui et l'entrée au
rôle dans votre campagne paix il dit
gilles décident ils ont plein d'idées
ils ont construit les centaines de
comités qui soutiennent ma candidature
et dans lesquels je vous le dis au
passage plus de 50% des gens n'ont
jamais appartenu à aucune formation
politique
ils sont donc vous directeur de campagne
en quelque sorte tout à fait vous avez
vu les candidats des autres candidats il
aimait chez les experts les vieux loups
de mer des mashav des violences et la
chine les experts beaucoup d'argent
jamais en a autant parlé de l'argent je
mets y en a autant eu ces ballons pour
qu'est ce que ça a donné ce que ça a
donné pour les français tous à 10
millions de budget de ma campagne c'est
clair jouer devant wii ou 10000 au
nouveau des millions de francs j'aurai
les autres en 150 millions etc
joël remboursement de 8 millions de
frais le reste ce sont des dons des
souscriptions et ces grosses machines
cette politique traditionnelle
hiérarchisée centralisée ça n'a pas
donné de très bons résultats
je crois que ce sont les gens eux-mêmes
tout ce qu'ils doivent se prendre en
charge et faire la politique c'est ça
qu'on voulu les mouvements des étudiants
des antiracistes ou des cheminots qui
l'a entendu vous dit manquer ça par
exemple vous où il est de ce racisme qui
a été longtemps un mouvement qui se
voulait apolitique et vous êtes en plein
maintenant campagne électorale ou
bouddha plus politique que ça coûte et
l'antiracisme n'a jamais était
apolitique je crois que quand nous
étions réunis au concert de la concorde
mois de juillet 85 avec mes potes nous
étions 350 milles et quand nous étions
rassemblés et que nous disions qu'il
fallait se battre contre le racisme
nous faisions de la politique nous
faisions de la politique autrement
nous disions qu'il était possible de
vivre dans cette société sans qu'on
pointe des boucs émissaires qui seraient
entre autres les immigrés et dans cette
campagne
y a pas de contradiction pour moi je
retrouve toutes les valeurs d'égalité de
solidarité de fraternité que j'ai
développée dans le cadre de ma démarche
anti raciste et je pense que vous voyez
là j'ai je vous amener toutes les
lettres que m'envoie les différents
comités qui se crée autour de la
nourriture des biens jusqu'à et bien il
ya beaucoup de lettres d'antiraciste qui
se reconnaissent dans la démarche de
pierre je tiens donc
non ils ne sont pas en contradiction et
vous
vous avez production mouvement des
étudiants 86 qui justement rejeté la
politique en bloc non non c'était
c'était autre chose
il réclamait son indépendance par
rapport aux partis politiques et il
avait raison j'étais d'accord avec ça
parce que c'était une garantie pour
maintenir son unité sa démocratie et sa
détermination alors par contre il se
battait contre une loi il exprimait des
valeurs très important d'égalité de
solidarité je vais vous donner un
exemple moi je me souviens avant d'aller
dans une assemblée générale il y à il ya
plusieurs étudiants qui viennent me voir
de première année qui me disent nous on
a fait une petite commission là et on
vient d'écrire une nouvelle constitution
pour la france alors pourtant se battait
et pourtant on se battait contre la loi
devaquet mais il ya eu des milliers
d'heures de discussions dans ces
assemblées générales ont parlé de tout
ce qui se passe dans la société dans le
monde
je crois que ça a été une prise de
conscience qu'on doit s'occuper des
affaires de la cité
c'est ça la politique qu'est ce qui vous
fait vous demander aux des jeunes des
immigrés c'est pas quand même à ça que
la france se ramène premièrement et
deuxièmement vous n'avez pas trouvé
d'experts on n'avait pas trouvé
d'économistes qui veut aussi travailler
avec vous et s'adresser par exemple aux
intellectuels aux chefs d'entreprises
etc
d'abord des jeunes des immigrés c'est
déjà très important mais il ya autour de
nous aussi beaucoup d'autres gens des
syndicalistes ou des non syndiqués qui
travaillent dans les entreprises grandes
et petites
il y à des experts et parmi ces experts
il ya aussi des syndicalistes par
exemple les nombreux universitaires qui
depuis des années refusé de participer à
toute recherche pour des hommes
politiques ou des mouvements politiques
sont venus spontanément plus de 150
travailler autour de moi ils ont
d'ailleurs créé toute une richesse mais
nos comités aussi ont beaucoup produit
je suis revenue de strasbourg où je suis
allé faire un meeting devant et 13 cents
personnes avec tout le paquet documents
sur le nucléaire sur l'autogestion et
c'est beaucoup de travail ce fait vous
savez je crois que
nous avons de très bons exemples par
exemple l'arsenal de brest
hall est une question qui est très
difficile voilà des gens qui se battent
depuis des années pour garder leur
emploi en défendant la construction
d'armes qui à la limite pour et rasé
toute la planète et faire disparaître
toute vie sur la surface de la planète
c'est pas moral pas de leur part de la
part du système qui leur imposent une
telle obligation
mais nous avons affronté le problème
n'en dit il faut cesser avec la course
aux armements
nous allons commencer à discuter au mois
de novembre quand ils se mêlent avec ace
étaient tous depuis la discussion s'est
continuée j'ai tenu l'engagement que
j'avais annoncé la télévision la semaine
dernière j'étais avec eux et surprise il
y avait des gens venus de nombreux
autres arsenault ils ont commencé
élaboré après avoir consultés par
questionnaires leurs collègues un plan
de transformation de l'entreprise en
construction civils je faisais un débat
blénod-lès-pont-à-mousson c'est en
lorraine et c'est la sidérurgie et à la
fin du meeting
il ya un vieux qui est venu me serrer la
main les larmes aux yeux et il m'a dit
toute ma vie j'ai été militant j'étais
dirigeant de la cgt dans la sidérurgie
lorraine
j'étais au parti communiste je me suis
battu ya eu la résistance et toutes ces
grandes luttes
eh bien aujourd'hui c'est la preuve la
première réunion où mon fils est avec
moi pour faire la même politique parce
qu' il n'était pas d'accord avec moi ils
trouvaient que on se creuser alors voilà
il ya des gens qui se rassemblent
il ya ya une continuité et je crois que
tout cela c'est c'est vraiment neuf
quand on explique aux gens que le droit
au travail c'est pas droit qui se coupe
c'est pas des gens qui ont droit au
travail et d'autres gens qui seraient
marquées du sceau de la famille du
chômage y'a pas des gens qui auraient
droit à une protection sociale et
d'autres qui en aurait pas y'a pas des
jeunes qui pourraient éventuellement
parce qu'ils sont bien nés avoir droit
au savoir
d'autres chez d'autres jeunes qui de
fait mal des autres audi mais aurait
comme seul horizon les tuques les sivp
la banlieue la zone
exemple adresse à tout à fait nous avons
eu un exemple très concret nous sommes
allés à dreux vous savez que le front
national fait un score très fort moi
même j'ai discuté avec un ouvrier qui
s'apprêtaient à voter pour le front
national
en dix ans c'était d'urgence dans
société dans une cité d'urgence on se
dira une vie très difficiles il avait
été licencié de son travail et il me
disait les difficultés qu'il rencontrait
pour trouver du travail pour assurer un
avenir à ses enfants et il appelait
entre autres un de ses enfants et son
fils est accompagné de deux autres
jeunes gens qui qui sont des beurs des
jeunes issus des migrations dont il est
n'est pas raciste au fond de lui-même
donc tout à fait je pense qu'il n'était
pas raciste mais parce qu'il ne
comprenait pas véritablement les
problèmes parce qu'on ne lui expliquer
pas la réalité des choses parce qu'on
lui mente est parce que les véritables
solutions sont pas celles de l'exclusion
sont pas celles de la marginalité sont
pas celles du racisme mais au contraire
il m'a dit voilà ces trois jeunes gens
il faut des tuques à 1200 francs
c'est insupportable pour déjà nouveau
décompte 16 ans 17 ans 18 ans il m'a dit
mais tu as dit que tu es mais où est la
gauche - la gauche qu'elle d'intérêt oui
la bouche ça veut dire qu'il ya vraiment
besoin de redonner espoir de redonner
confiance aux gens en les rassemblant
autour d'objectifs d'idées dont la
gauche n'aurait jamais dû s'éloigner
vous savez je suis le seul candidat à
dire tous les jours dans les débats que
je fais car monde seront pas de meeting
nous n'avons que des débats avec les
gens à dire tous les jours que toute la
classe politique porte une
responsabilité par ses petites lâchetés
par ses insuffisances par son incapacité
à résoudre des problèmes
toute la classe politique porte une
responsabilité dans la montée de le pen
et du front national
souvenez vous avant que le mouvement
étudiant se développe
c'était au secours la droite revient
qu'ils allaient penser que la suite la
droite serait dans une situation de tel
aujourd'hui à la veille de l'élection
présidentielle c'est ce mouvement qui a
changé on parlait du libéralisme
triomphant
aujourd'hui on parle de la progression
des valeurs de solidarité d'égalité
alors je crois que en misant sur ce qui
bouge on se rend compte que non la
société n'est pas en train de virer à
droite comme certains à gauche le 10 ou
bien comme d'autres le disent ce n'est
pas en attendant que les français un
jour soit d'accord il faut miser sur ce
qu'il ya de meilleur dans la société
dans ce qui ce qui bouge et je crois que
les français comme les immigrés de ce
pays d'un seront aller vers l'égalité
dans sap dans la société
si je vous remets j'écoute tout ça
expose j'ai évidemment lu beaucoup de
choses à votre propos depuis deux ou
trois jours vous me demandez de vous
interroger ce que je crois comprendre
donc c'est que à gauche et puis aussi
hors de la politique on cherchait
quelqu'un qui puisse représenter notre
manière de voir la vie et la
géopolitique est l'homme providentiel en
quelque sorte c'est pierre juquin c'est
ça un homme providentiel
un homme providentiel vous croyez qu'on
a besoin d'un homme providentiel
vous croyez que les jeunes qui sont avec
moi s'il me prenait pour un homme
providentiel il souhaite avec moi mais
mes 4 et dre rooney est ce que vous
pensez que j'ai fait tout ce parcours
difficile pour recommencer ce que j'ai
vécu et ce que je vois dans le monde
politique traditionnelle quand j'entends
david kaïs à développer cette nécessité
cette urgence de la fraternité de
l'égalité de la démocratie transparente
cette urgence d'une politique différente
du rassemblement d'une unité mais c'est
tout le contraire d'un homme
providentiel des hommes providentiels où
les que je dise s'en est plaint à la
télévision des grands et des petits
les hommes providentiels s'en est plaint
dans les cimetières touche irremplaçable
quelle vanité ce n'est pas d'une idole
dont nous avons besoin c'est d'idées
d'idées neuves et d'idées neuves que
nous allons faire encore avancer
ensemble à gauche par l'action je
voudrais vous poser une dernière
question peuple peu provoc rhdp qui est
la suivante qu'est ce qu'ils me prouvent
à moins qu'ils nous écoutent par exemple
que vous n'allez pas reproduire
fidèlement le système nous existions
auquel vous avez des répondants aussi
l'otan parce qu'après tout si un
mouvement sera sans doute de vous faudra
bien une organisation faudra bien parti
pour que tout ça fonctionne
rien ni personne ne le prouve ça dépend
des gens eux mêmes je suis bien placé à
l'âge que j'ai pour savoir que tous les
hommes politiques en position de leader
son sujet aux petites défaillances ou à
la tentation de devenir des vedettes sur
les médias alors je crois qu'il ya qu
une solution si nous voulons faire un
mouvement vraiment neuf et changer
quelque chose dans la vie politique
française c'est que les gens comme moi
soient mis par tous les citoyens qui se
bat avec eux sous haute surveillance
ce peut pas être programme c'est pas un
programme
c'est un garde-fou c'est une nécessité
absolue vous savez je voudrais dire
quelque chose aux gens qui nous
regardent tout le monde cite jaurès en
même temps en ce moment mais il ya un
mot de jaurès que personne ne cite en
s'adressant aux travailleurs de carmaux
il leur disait un jour
attention ne passait pas l'outil à un
autre fait changer le monde vous même et
bien fait le changer nous vous aiderons
[Musique]